Do you have the methylated B vitamins at home?
So, let's go to this slide here.
So, methylated B vitamins would be five methyl tetrahydrovolate,
or it would be, or I should say, methyl cobalamine.
If you have those products at home, so five methyl tetrahydrovolate is your methylated folate,
and methyl cobalamine is your methylated B12.
We just want to start taking some of that.
And you should start at, make sure you're taking, I would say, less than one gram of this per day.
Oops.
So, if it's 500 milligrams, or 1000 milligrams, don't take any more than that.
There are some supplements on the market that are like five grams of methyl tetrahydrofolate,
do not start with something like that.
Taking too much methyl tetrahydrofolate will push a different pathway called the biopterate pathway,
really, really hard.
And if you have any defects in the biopterate pathway, you're going to have some emotional issues,
because you can create way too much serotonin.
That's the most common thing.
And then you get some rage issues, and we don't want you beating anybody up or hurting your spouse.
So, methyl cobalamine, there's really no upper limit on this within reason.
So any of the supplements that are out there with the methyl cobalamine,
what's on the bottle for that?
Make sure you don't take it any more than one gram of the methyl tetrahydrofolate.